two diagrams that I use to find the foci
and the director sees directly
contradict one another so that's a
recipe for confusing yourself if you
slam them together so I'm gonna do one
for the foci which are more
straightforward than normal for the
director season
now the foci first we know roughly are
quite talkative before we know roughly
where they are it's somewhere roughly we
expect it to be there right it should be
about 1.4 times further from the origin
then the vertex right there does that
make sense so I'm going to take
advantage of that right knowing that and
I've drawn in green the transverse axis
to help us with the geometry of it
knowing that the focus should lie on the
transverse axis if it has part of what
makes it the face besides I think on
line like so right and that distance
which I've just drawn on that interval
because it's from this hyperbola right
it should be identical to this distance
do you agree with that those two
distances are the same so I know what
that distance is it's Richard tante
now to find where the focus is all I
need is the x coordinate and the y
coordinate well the x coordinate is this
distance here across and the y
coordinate is this distance here
downwards okay and because it's the X&Y
I taught a write angular
but the beautiful thing about this is
the fact that I know that because this
point is on the transverse axis why an X
should be the same number you agree with
that let's say none so if I call this X
then that means this also it must be X
right do you agree with that so now I
turn this whoa clinics fancy I've turned
it into a Pythagoras okay so by
Pythagoras in that black triangle I can
say x squared plus x squared equals root
2a or squared that's the hypotenuse and
it kind of falls out from here what the
x value is I've got two x squared equals
2a squared
yep divide through
and again this movie about me now so
that might be like wait what how does
that work because x equals plus or minus
it was significant to us before but for
a different reason
it's when the vertices were do you see
that whatever attended around right this
distance here has preserved but it's no
longer horizontally at the same point
okay so now the focus is that well one
of them will be at a comma a because X
are the same and the other one we are
here at minus a minus so that's the
various thumbs up now I'm going to pull
much the same trick to work out the
director seems okay first I'll do one
directrix and then the other one just
trying to comes along for pride I know
it again from my rough plotting out and
will keep my original episode that my
directrix should be here listen to the
origin that the vertex that corresponds
do so something like this
ish now like I said I'm gonna take a
bunch of job number one the transverse
axis and number two the fact that I know
along the transverse axis exactly how
far away the directors should be it
corresponds to that interval there you
see that that interval it corresponds to
this interval and I know it's exactly
it's a number two so in there I write
now from there I've got a couple of
different parts architect okay I could
do like perpendicular distance formula
so what the orange there the trainee etc
but to me I might as well just use the
approach I used before word if I know a
point on this line I already know its
gradient we already established that
before so then I can just put it to
point B so you write anger triangle for
exactly the same reason because that
point is on the transverse axis it's not
only a right angle triangle but it's
also these so now I know am x squared
plus x squared
note the different Express the
difference is equal to a on root 2 all
squared
thank sometimes we need like two x
squared and a a squared on too happy
with that so far but here instead of the
twos just can turn out here it makes it
worse so I get x squared on four
so when I go and take the square root
I'm getting half that distance does that
make sense
but that should make sense right because
look the directrix is so much closer
than the focus in fact it's exactly
now how is this what I'm doing this
thing yeah so now I know the coordinates
at that point it hands you a onto so I'm
going to put that into point into sense
sorry
great we'll put rated for right so but
why minus the y-coordinate equals and I
know what the gradient is it's minus 1
so minus X minus x1 there it is okay and
it's beautiful it just pops out like
this minus X plus a or 2 plus a or 2 so
y equals that guy right and of course
I've got its cousin which is going the
other way
so I guess I would have
as X minus a I guess to take advantage
of this